hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde und ich sind sie heute nicht
allein sondern sie dann jeden tag um
gott was ich für nur zeit kommt neue
sexy bild von mir alle kommentieren und
liken also reagieren heute gemeinsam auf
die hilfe folge amazing horse mein
geheimes doppelleben und sandra dieses
mal ganz kurz die video beschreibung vor
damit die so groß ist und was es heute
geht es statt 30 hat eine heimliche
leidenschaft sie verkleidet player also
gut ich pack aus also verschläge seit
zwei jahren ein hocken und das nehme ich
das kostüm und kleide mich als fährt er
jetzt schon genug von sandras lacher
habt dann schaltet am besten jetzt ab
denn jetzt wird noch schlimmer jetzt
noch zum sport geht schon wieder sind
sport wenn ich jetzt alles schon wieder
alle also wenn du hast dich doch mal für
mich zeit müssen jetzt gehst du mir was
die zahnarzthelferin zwei polizisten
weiß er dass die firmen egal wir haben
nicht mal gemeinderat also das ist ja
gerade alles noch diese was bisher
geschah zusammenfassung also wir sind
doch nicht meine richtigen folge
angekommen ja ich mag zwar werde aber
ich kann nicht reifen noch nicht aber
vielleicht nicht hier könnte ihnen eine
kostenlose alt stimme geben
[Musik]
ich habe stress mit anuschka man ich
glaube dass sie mich beschloss mit ihrem
verdammten chef dem zahnarzt wir haben
der slow digital aus praxis gehen könnte
ist und so tue stattfinde irgendwie was
mit den zähnen hättest kalt haben
der will jetzt sein kumpel der
arztpraxis zu gehen und zu sagen okay
wir sind jetzt übrigens auch wieder in
der folge angekommen also jetzt geht es
so richtig los die zusammenfassung ist
quasi zu ende du bist ein patient wie
jeder andere darauf stand schon bitter
hier geht es um eine er klagt er so
stimmt schon
dafür blickt seien so tief in die
zahnarztpraxis herausfinden ob seine
frau bescheid weiß genau wie ich brauche
auch solche freunde würde dir dass du
hast keine freunde wandere ich weiß aber
ihr könnt mir auf sanders fi saga
schreiben befreundet sein wollte halt
einfach dein maul bekommen
dieser kurze nacht er war schon da an
ich darf dir die zeit zeigen
okay gut aber erzählt ja jetzt warum er
oder würde nicht warum er in der praxis
war aber dass er in der praxis war und
jetzt finden wir heraus ob er gesehen
hat dass deine frau was mit dem typen
hatte meine vielschichtigen richtig übel
alltag was sie mal kurz das geht gar
nicht mehr klar wer soll denn füße ab
oder waren die ganze zeit nicht sagen so
krank ist und das ist eigentlich nicht
man es gar nicht selbst so richtig ein
zudem findet man ja eigentlich mache ist
geschmackvoll oder ein bisschen nach
gleich zum nachdenken ein bisschen nach
vorn und zurück
eigentlich müssen ihre noch den hilfen
anderer 24 ich habe das problem dass
ihre füße unfassbar deutsch stehen
helfen jugendlichen 2000 jahre später
hast du bald man ja was ist da sagte ich
jetzt raus aber eigentlich auf einer
wiese prozent auf den fernseher
handlung dicker was fragt wieso ross auf
geht's auf geht jetzt aber er ist aber
gut marathon barth lässt die tür offen
danach ist der ton packe ich bin angst
wenn ich fit bin weil ich denke dass mir
jeden morgen aufs maul
es wären also wenig brauchen aggressiven
kurs wird ob damals nur im sinn gehabt
wie der arzt seinen ring absätze und
andere störung hier hatten wir mal in
unserem leben halten kontakt gehalten
habt jetzt von anfang an gewusst hat der
hat den ring abgenommen die suchen
andauern augenkontakt hast du selber
gerade sagt ist doch ganz klar vater
läuft er von
glaubst du dir etwas mit dem typen
ich hab's vielleicht will ja dass sie
sich als wird verklagt weil er das geil
findet glaubt ich war jetzt schon jetzt
ist natürlich der pferde absolut am
dampfen ist er eifersüchtig und denkt
sie geht fremd dabei galoppiert zu
wahrscheinlich hier auf der wiederum
ohne worte nicht und nein love
wasserschloss europas setzen dem 100
euro
es war daniela katzenberger mutter die
der rat gesprochen hat die psychologin
woher weißt du dass beiderseits hey das
ist 100 prozent zulegen die psychologen
aber die sitzen einfach den blick in
richtung geht jetzt auf jeden fall in
die arztpraxis dass mein freund
sie ist doch schon raus musste hat mir
selber heute erzählt dass sie länger
machen muss
sie hatte feiern doch gerade richtig das
war sie doch sie sind doch die frau von
zahn als richtig
kennen sie eigentlich hatte läuft was
meinen sie was eine frau geht mit ihrem
mann reiten hat sie eingeladen ich gehe
jetzt rein
das war von mir sind sie überhaupt das
tut mir sehr leid
entschuldigung ich jetzt gar nichts mehr
geht gar nichts mehr
jackson einig dass die frau liegt da
jetzt aber da es auf einmal nächste eine
frau die zwei kaninchen mit langer
zoffen
wieso jetzt aber ein wenig rau geht der
arzt heißen würde dort geben hier arzt
weil sie das sandra sell fisahn drauf
insel die zähne kontrollieren ecke und
danach können wir auch noch woanders
sehen möchte dass er seine zahnbürste im
mund schiebt nur ein und daher
beschenken ist so ich hoffe noch von ihr
unser konto einer damit sie dich
beeindrucken kann
wir wollen war mit meiner frau reiten
kannst doch er hat sie zum reiten
eingeladen und das geht schon seit
ewigkeiten sonst sagt auch das hobby
reiten die wahl hielt wie gedruckt
da ist er hardcore aggressiv zahnschmerz
ja ich bin gestolpert gestolperten
stolpern hat wo hast du denn gestolpert
ja auf entstand ein heim steinmann musst
du es ist jetzt genug die lügerei die
ähnlichkeit liebst du mich an du sollst
ja was geht habt warum sagt annika eben
nicht die wahrheit wenn zwei auf einmal
gerettet das ziethen hat den schwanz
hinterher ja mädel macht die klappe auf
ich bin ein pferd staatliche louisa lo
was machst du hier
was machst du hier sag mal dachte er
trifft die schirm mit dem zahnarzt
freund ja ich kann ob ihre wie ein pferd
jetzt warnungen und die ob die wähler
seien die was nicht auch sein guckt
immer an wie du aussiehst gehört das
passiert immer dann nicht mehr gewusst
[Gelächter]
andersen hatte ich das heute wieder
beende meine lieben freunde total viele
von euch an unserem eine letzte hilfe
der action geschrieben dass ich das
nächste mal zusammen mit sandra auf
hilfen reagieren soll
ich mag den chef wenn euch das video ja
heute auf jeden fall gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
das schreibt uns und in die kommentare
auf was wir das nächste mal zusammen
reagieren sondern auch für das
eventuelle überhaupt noch mal machen
und jetzt main kanal falls noch keinen
teil der lu kruse und ersthelfer seiner
crew war wir sind viel geiler
[Musik]